President Trump is warning the US will
strike back harder than ever if it is
attacked Iran has vowed revenge for a US
drone strike that killed its top
military commander on Friday
mourners have filled the streets of the
southwestern Iranian city of Avaz where
the remains of commander Qasem Soleimani
have been returned from Iraq meanwhile
more US troops headed to the region
soldiers and equipment left North
Carolina for Kuwait adding to the
hundreds who left there earlier this
week Iraq two Shiite Muslims have
marched in funeral processions to show
their grief the Prime Minister has
declared three days of national mourning
mourning and anger are in the air as the
funeral procession for Iran's top
general Qasem Soleimani
and Iraqi commander Abu Mukhtiar
Mohandas arrives at the holy shrine in
Najaf thousands have come to pay their
respects here in Iraq on the streets of
Tehran to hear Iranians demanded
vengeance after a US strike in Baghdad
on Friday killed
sulemani we will avenge your generous
death he was not just an individual but
a whole country they did not just kill
one person they killed the country
all Iranians loved him he was the
general of our hearts I haven't been
feeling well since yesterday it's like
I've lost my own father the pain I feel
won't be gone until we take revenge
soleymani was the mastermind behind
Iran's military engagement in the Middle
East for the last two decades and a
close ally of Iran's supreme leader and
the revenge for his death seems already
to have started on Saturday a rocket
fell inside Baghdad's heavily fortified
Green Zone near the u.s. embassy another
on an air base housing US troops
it comes after Iranian president Hassan
Rani vowed during a meeting with
Shalimar nice daughter that his country
will retaliate mr. rouhani when the
blood of my father's friends were shed
he would take revenge for them now who
is going to take revenge for my father's
blood they will everyone will get
revenge for the martyrs blood don't you
worry about that meanwhile US President
Trump warned that the u.s. is ready to
respond should Iran strike any Americans
or American assets Trump has repeatedly
of claimed that Suleiman is killing was
necessary to protect American lives
Tehran has appointed general s mal Ghani
to replace soleimani he'll now be
responsible for Iran's foreign military
operations
journalist Amir Misawa joins me here in
the studio on Mir so glad you could be
with us I want our viewers to take a
look at some live pictures that were
getting in right now from Iran before we
start our conversation this is thousands
of mourners now they're following this
funeral procession for the slain
officers that huge turnout one can
imagine is meant clearly as a sign of
unity how unified is the country behind
the regime right now I think the time
that some people criticizing the regime
in Iran is in this states at least it's
not enough loud enough I think
the unity of the Iranian nation become
more and more through that cessation of
missile Qasem Soleimani
we just saw that footage over the
yesterday in Iraq by the way also that
some Iraqis have also some criticizing
against soleimani but what we saw
yesterday for the whole the footage in
Najaf and in Karbala that Iraqis
burning the bodies of mr. Sulu Manning
and Abu mati and Mohandas it is also a
kind of unifying just not forget that
the the footage that we cut it today
from Iran coming from the city which the
majority of them is Arabs it is the west
of Iran and Hawass and this is also a
kind of a message towards the United
States that your uranium people are
unified all are that action of the
United States there's a lot of messaging
going on I mean the US president Donald
Trump has warned that he has 52 targets
in Iran in mind if he is provoked or Ron
Ian's taking him seriously I think this
is a control country production that he
brought the love the old things happen
in the past its counterproductive you
saying I'm not productive yet it's not
productive because with that he bring it
Brennan more and more unified themself
remembering that time that when the
Americans try to to save that
52 hostages in 1979 and it's the
operation felt and I think Iranian
remembering that that action from the
United States that it was not successful
enough and they think that this this
threat is will not be powerful enough I
think now if I would give an advice for
mister fromm I think the the message
that he consent for the diplomatic
docking to find a solution for that this
is maybe better than bringing 52 number
in this message journalist Amir Masari
thanks so much for your time y'all
straight time